Stewart has gave voice to many people's
frustration at the moment including
conservative voters because what the
conservatives have shown themselves to
do especially over the last couple of
years is not what they would consider to
be conservative you know we've had low
growth high taxes we've had cuts to our
Public Services we've had the economy
that has been crashed so I'm not
surprised that Rod Stewart has looked at
that anyone can look at this
government's record and see that they
failed and that we need change now and
the fact that Rod Stewart was able to
see also the plan that labor has is um
you know humbling for me and care and
the rest of the labor team who knew we
had to change the party we knew we had
to listen to the voters and that
hopefully they can see we've got a plan
to make things better into the future